the Riddler has actually been
manipulating all of the super villains
who is Robert Pattinson Batman in this
murder dungeon based off of a jigsaw HH
Holmes type figure there's where the
penguin could be the guy they hire to
fix the baseball team rock stars Phillip
Molina this is rogue theory today we're
talking about which Batman villain Jonah
Hill was apparently going to play on
today's episode we have a comedian Leo
Garcia and frequent contributor marina
Westeros Oh happen so many times there's
also on this episode later we're gonna
have some theories about a dangling
thread from a vendor's endgame you
thought we found them all but you can
just pull more out of family okay so I'm
gonna establish some rules here some
rogue e's are up for grabs wrote nine
and it's gonna be based on the best or
most rogue theory or most different if
they're if your theories are bad then
we'll switch to rogue reward that so
Jonah Hill is in negotiations to play a
villain in the Robert Pattinson version
of the Batman and it's very nasty
negotiations apparently actually I'm
having a lot of trouble settling down on
what character he should play he
apparently they wanted to play someone
who is not a flattering body type he's
like no I want to be too in his opinion
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
come up with our best or most Rhodes
theories they distinguish between like
you can either be good or just be rogue
is like saving me right
in life by the way good or you can be
the road villain
so speaking of those rogue villains I
want to hear your pitch on here's the
villain he should play in this exact
story okay so my pitch for who should
play is the Riddler okay okay The
Riddler yep but specifically in the hush
comic book like pause spoiler warning
for hush right because I know that story
and you're about to say some fascinating
stuff if you want to read hush hit pause
go bye hush read it real quick you come
back just real quick
then come back to this exact place where
you pause this in podcaster this YouTube
video and so he's the one from the hush
comic timeline so he's a super genius
right and he manipulates basically all
of the other super villains to like I
want to say to mess with Batman at the
same time but also they're not doing it
in the ways that they typically would so
like Batman as he's like fighting all
these people on an individual individual
basis he's like wait like this does this
is poison ivy but it doesn't seem like
something she'd typically typically do
and after a series of encountering a
bunch of obstacles like that he also
falls and cracks his head open and has
to get brain surgery that may or may not
be a part of it but after all of this he
discovers that the Riddler has actually
been manipulating all of the super
villains and at the beginning the
Riddler is kind of like the Rudolph of
like the Rudolph the Red Nosed they
won't play with him Nick they don't
respect him he's like kind of a lesser
villain like he's Rudolph he just is
like you know there and then at the end
it's like a dark timeline of Rudolph and
at the end he basically shows like hey
[ __ ] I like managed to
manipulate all of you and control all of
you and he find out find out the
identity of Batman but doesn't reveal it
because that would be because of a
riddle that everybody has the answer to
you wouldn't be good so he's gonna keep
that secret forever and it's a great
role for Jonah Hill because it's a huge
role right like it's
the entire film is around him about him
he causes the entire plot line it's from
start to finish it's like basically
about him though is though in hush right
that's kind of like a big secret not
misleading direction it goes in but
there's there's a whole mystery about
this whole other character yeah there
are rumors that there will be more
villains in it if they haven't actually
said that it's going to be his normal
rogues gallery but it will be some
element of the Rogues
yeah so so but hush is like I mean
Superman's even in hush so it could be
all those interesting options it's good
because there's lots of options I love
the idea just of a story where Rudolf
that uses the other reindeer to kill Sam
[Music]
there's an elf out there that's been
killing people but that's just just a
misdirect yeah it's really rude off his
controlling yeah yeah show up early and
hush I think he's like robbing a bank or
something right and it's not I think
it's like Nightwing or something there's
just like and that's how a Batman
figures out he's like wait that crime
was beneath Riddler he'd want to work in
some riddles to this and it's like later
he's like that's how I figured out it
was you the bank I'm into it he he plays
the Riddler but I like this exact
version of the Riddler that we were kind
of just touch down there where he's not
impressive right you can beat him up
easily he has to squeeze into that Jim
Carrey outfit
I just really embarrassed him and then
turn out well I am the smartest person
here
I'm not counting persuading so he
manipulated the whole cast I loved that
part it also feels appropriate for Jonah
Hill's trying to you know always show
off like no I'm not just that kid from
40 L version like exactly he's been
trying to prove that so it would give
him a lot of ability like he gets to
wear cool outfit at the end not in the
beginning but at the end especially I
mean especially in this like new DC
universe like where Joker is gonna
probably win another oscar like he could
take yeah he could take Riddler who is
typically seen as something silly and
like say I'm gonna make this an Oscar
gunning for it
winning yeah performance oh man I don't
like you'd be like really is like
pushing it where he's like has a lot of
chewing up the scene kind of it's like
you know crying and laughing into a
mirror like what is the answer question
mark on his face like in a little boy's
mouth ever seen the trailer of Joker
remembering cool all right one Reggie
signed to Marina let's hear the next
rogue theory okay so I have sort of two
theories fighting you in every turn my
first super rock theory is just the fact
that this new Joker is sort of a
combination of taxi driver King of
Comedy and the idea that they're trying
to earn credits by sort of parody nor
like amping or like you know taking from
these old classics yeah like like
recreating these classic and so
essentially the idea being that two
rogue E's know so far I'm kind of into
this idea of if you know they taking
these classics that a lot of people
haven't haven't seen yet yeah and giving
them a new new life
so this is just Jonah Hill in this
version he'd be cast as his character
from the movie Moneyball and he's he's
hired by a police lab Bruce Wayne who
owns who owns the Gotham guardians listo
the Gotham Guardians and he's got a he's
got you know somehow turn that team
around and he's using he's using
sabermetrics base of RBIs
he's using more he's gonna he's using
Wars using going I'm taking your road
morena make him stop alright here's my
other one bang I think there's an option
where Jonah Hill will have to play the
character he probably is fighting
against plain due to all his body
transformation he sort of stuck between
body types and you've mostly left one
and he'd probably end up playing the
penguin I think I know obviously the
penguin doesn't have to be any size all
the Penguins that said penguins yes
they're short pear-shaped they're short
or your penguin shapes yeah their
penguin shaped and so they play not
gonna be ripped but ostensibly he would
play the way that I'm factoring is if
this would be like a noir serial killer
story is that like perhaps a young
penguin is sort of rising the ranks of
Gotham's crime world and in some ways is
maybe through his own sort of you know
more dastardly ways trying to kill the
serial killer as well and him in Batman
are both trying both trying to catch
this killer just by different means I
think there would be a world where he he
thinks he's doing right but in doing so
is sort of going against what Batman
believes okay but like what what's he
doing oh he's trying to he's trying to
suss out who the serial killer or
whoever this is on the loose just like
beating people yeah by getting his goons
to do to find this guy and maybe he's
killing errantly killing people who he
thinks are they so it's sort of
misfiring and you know the bloodshed
becomes too much so Batman has to kind
of put both him and whatever serial
killer in check by the end of it okay
alright I'm kind of feeling it feels
like a low action action yeah yeah well
I think they they will probably have
some fight scenes but I I do like date a
bit being pretty noir you can't even get
a full row because you made a swath
through the earlier I wanted to tell me
more about this
we'll get a Rogi for the rest of the
show we hear anymore about Moneyball
villain unless he's a character named
Moneyball and now it starts to become
funny he's a ball of what he's a super
genius money just like a snowball of
collected dollar bills and eventually
one gets paid where the penguin could be
the guy they hire to fix the baseball
team okay here's my theory so I think if
we are thinking Jonah Hill wants to take
this beast he wants to win an Oscar we
have to assume everyone wants to be
Batman he's been nominated for Moneyball
but he wants to win an Oscar how what's
another strategy to win an Oscar you
play someone who is a historical figure
you do a biopic so if we look at a lot
of Batman villains as people we'll taken
from real world figures a Batman was
famously based off of Teddy Roosevelt
right a self-made you know wealthy man
who learned jujitsu and what did you see
what other martial arts hold on dive
into this is this Batman is famously
based on Teddy Roosevelt I learned this
from you my friend it was man story like
one of the influences I'm not saying the
predominant influence was Teddy
Roosevelt but Teddy Roosevelt was a
wealthy kid who was born with these
afflictions and had to basically
reinvent himself to be a crime fighter
and he was a police commissioner of New
York City and busted up a lot of these
crime lords and basically won back the
city of New York and that was what he
built his political fortunes on and rose
to the presidency he was shot during a
speech and like fight through it and
finish the speech he's a major badass
the social history element so if we look
at Batman's story that way you forgot
you said it from the Victorian era of
United States history if Teddy Roosevelt
was a
greatest hero who is a greatest villain
serial killer of that era HH Holmes the
greatest American serial killers
demantoid City Chicago World's Fair turn
of the century they had the World's Fair
at Chicago when he used this a lot of
people were flocking to this city
he built basically a murder Castle a
hotel that he would have people stay in
and that he was secret rigging up with
booby traps to drop people into rooms
where they would be suffocated or gassed
he would chop people up he would
cadavers would go missing he's a monster
children in a suitcase
yes very fun for him now the character
of HH Holmes he's a real person the
character of jigsaw some say was
partially based on HH Holmes as a serial
killer who locks people into these
dungeons they have to try to work their
way out he messes with their heads so
how does this work in the world of
Batman well we've talked about this idea
of Arkham Asylum being turned into this
kind of like death trap maze that Batman
gets locked in as has been the case in
the Arkham Asylum games
what if Jonah Hill is plain Hugo Strange
this psychiatrist who works at Arkham
Asylum but now in this world it's this
abandoned place at his head villains who
have broken out of it and now they live
there because they prefer to live there
it's his world he is doing human
experimentation including we're talking
about Andy Serkis being in a villain
maybe maybe any circus is Clayface in
this and he's like just kill me but so
that's a character that Jonah Hill's
playing he's playing it's a chin beard
beard psychologist who is Robert
Pattinson Batman in this murder dungeon
based off of a jigsaw HH Holmes type
figure and is breaking down his
psychosis to force him to encounter
other like genetically experimented in
patchwork Frankenstein and other Batman
villains
to destroy him and he asked to fight
each past villain with ultimately Jonah
Hill is Arkham at that point he's like
working his way through Arkham it also
kind of sounds like a little bit like
Silent Hill in terms of like here's
here's this abandoned Asylum that these
characters aren't quite who they are I
really liked it it was actually gonna
give you more rogue ease blues points
but because you were starting to head
toward a thing we were like it was gonna
be HH Holmes like for real or it was
like 1890s better a Batman story the
exact in the lighthouse you wouldn't
have too much work for him to look like
1890 see that excites me a lot so I'll
give myself a rogue a player in the game
I just get to redistribute it later well
I get paid in money you guys so I'll and
I also really liked the idea of working
through Arkham you kind of had like a
scattershot approach it's like yes
you'll like something in beer man okay
so Rose gallery city what do you like
true crime podcasts and playing the
Arkham games there's something for
healing your tinder profile okay so
let's go down the line and before I
actually have you guys read summarize
your point I want to focus on this Jonah
Hill angle first I can I see the
chinstrap you beautifully like even
podcast listeners could only see
chinstraps but now I want to know just
give me that this portrayal of in your
story what Jonah Hill is gonna be so you
know how kind of like the characters get
reinvented a lot in these modern
versions of these films what is Jonah
Hill's interpretation of for instance
the Riddler well I think they might do a
younger like literally a flashback of
him
like as a kid it seems like the scrawny
little kid but then because Jonah hell
wants to do this he gets to get super
buff so he gets to not be the penguin he
gets to be like super buff and like he
lives out his childhood fantasy of like
I'm attractive I'm fit and I'm a super
genius all you kids who bullied me is
like F when we were kids are wrong and
none of you signed my high school my
high school yearbook but now it's full
of signatures [ __ ] his own
mother fathers what's his like it was
his real-world profession that is like
the equivalent you know give him like
because he's associated with knowledge
you know he's the keeper of not like he
knows everything he knows the answers to
everything interesting okay cool
all right that sounds like a real like
buff nerdy role mine also he starts out
as a kid who gets bullying most people
do the baby and to kid who gets bullied
kids sounds a lot like yours except it's
because of his size he's a bigger kid
but then he does try it ever - this is
penguin this is and so I think it's also
I mean Robert Pattinson and Jonah Hill
are pretty similar in age are both like
mid-30s it's like the idea would be that
like he's he's a young ya cross while
they're there
he's a young version of the penguin I
would say like I think like a young
Carmen Falcone like he's sure he's
starting to put it together he's wearing
these like bigger suits but like they
still don't he doesn't feel like he's so
it's kind of like the mob bosses son
kind of yeah there's a little bit even
though like that's not what his family
is into but he has the money to sort of
do so maybe he's he's a classmate of
Bruce Wayne's when they're growing up
and they're both very rich but Bruce
Wayne his father's a famous doctor this
kid's father is a mob boss yeah well
Bruce Bruce Wayne also I think usually
in stories is like
very athletic even as a child like they
do like he would be the bully
potentially to penguin yeah well even if
he's just the the one that's getting all
the accolades whatever that's enough for
some people to hate someone and then
finally he gets his uh I think his
occupation is he's a general manager of
a man I don't even want to go back here
now we'll go back to you because I want
to know why is he the penguin what like
detail about this dude is there like but
the only name that makes sense is the
penguin did he log fish what's up I
think it's very clear well he uses he
actually does use a monocle okay to like
comb-over baseball statistics catcher's
mitt nothing is explaining why he's the
penguin penguins don't actually wear
monocles also if he looks like a Marlin
why is he not the Marlin there's no
reason for the person to be the penguin
okay he's the penguin because as I said
the suits maybe don't are ill-fitting
and so and also he's been trying to like
lose this weight so bright he's wearing
bigger penguins look like they're
wearing tuxedos or don't fit yeah and so
he's wearing like Hammer pants like MC
Hammer pants the low type yeah and then
your we know chinstrap what else he did
not start as a child always as a man no
he's a operates out of nowhere
killing Murphy from The Dark Knight
movie started as like a psychologist
honestly Harley Quinn started as a as a
psychologist start a psychologist and
then just there on a narrow path and
they tip the other way no he is working
as you know I kind of like thinking him
as the as the owner of the he's not the
owner he's just a warden of the prison
in Silence of the Lambs who's just like
torturing his inmates
that's how Jonah Hill starts in this
world he wants to experiment to try to
improve their state their mental state
and to fix them but when they don't fix
the way he wants them to fix he has to
force them to become the monstrosity
that he imagines them to be so that plus
a chinstrap is in a monocle I'm a big
fan of this like Josef Mengele version
yeah it's like experimenter on people
but also kind of like Dexter he's
experimenting on the worst people so
you're kind of okay with that right yeah
well we're not calling out is that day
he might be creating the villains right
hey what if I mix you with crocodile
Danny yeah I want to see a like a
clinical approach the way that like dr.
Frankenstein is someone who believes
that he can make the superior man by
just like stitching to put stitching
together parts of criminals that he digs
up but these are living criminals that
he's taking parts of their bodies and
stitching together and and maybe using
other kind of experiments to breed a new
race of things to torture Batman with in
DC in any trouble okay so let's hear
your overall theory again in a tweet
tweet
[Music]
super-smart Jonah Hill is super smart
Riddler hashtag Rudolph revenge not but
without clarifying why Rudolph is a
Rudolf Hess it's also called Cobblepot
named GM of Gotham Guardians Jonah Hill
plays Hugo Strange a sadistic HH Holmes
asked owner of Arkham Asylum as a murder
castle tag hashtag all right I'm most
into three to one on this so we'll do
three yeah then Murray nice like there's
actually two risen with this time there
are ways for you to come back here's why
youyou care your wish comes that you
guys submitted wishes before the show
and whoever wins Joe gets our wish to
come true and Leo is medical and you
really need I wanna we'll get to the
wishes later but we have another theory
that we want to go into alright so there
was a fan on reddit we at what is a
double whip whip G or something right
whip G was pointing out this issue in
the current timeline of the MCU based on
the events of Avengers endgame so
remembering that 2014 Thanos comes to
our modern time and is the one that they
fight at the end and Captain Marvel
destroys his ship the sanctuary - and
whatnot but the other Thanos who gets
his head chopped off earlier also has
this amazing ship the sanctuary -
that was not destroyed that's out there
there's also just in general
danos tech out there and stuff which
we've learned a lot about and that it's
some of the most advanced stuff we saw
his sword tear apart Captain America
shield right yeah so these things are
all out there so I want to know what are
the implications of theoretical
implications of Thanos his ship still
being out there sanctuary 2 and it which
is like the probably most capable ship
we've ever been introduced to sure in in
the MCU and just in general his tech
like his sword how could that affect the
future of the MCU since they're still
around sure I mean okay so the sanctuary
2 is like the MCU equivalent of what a
Star Destroyer or the Death Star maybe
an entire planet yeah it's a massive
battleship that raining fire could wipe
out like the universe is two most
powerful armies if left unchecked so
that's floating out there cuz yeah we're
talk about like farmer Thanos right like
weird great cooking show Thanos so that
ships still out there somewhere we know
from the battle there was the battle at
the end of infinity war in Wakanda that
most of the Black Order had died um so a
lot of his outrider armies gone it's
been cold in half but yeah the ships
still out there at the end of far from
home we saw Nick Fury on a mysterious
Skrull ship right and we've done some
explanations of this that this could be
the peak you know the sword which is the
new offshoot group of shield in the
comics so yeah in the comics you have
shield which is like the strategic
homeland you know it's a wanted it's
spell shield yeah they got into it later
in the comics fury leaves shield and he
ends up being involved with sword which
is also an acronym but sword as both
shield shield protects earth sword is
kind of like interplanetary defense they
they keep an eye out in the cosmos and
they see things that are coming but
they're kind of orbiting the planet
Earth on this base called the peak it's
like a space station and so we're
wondering that maybe that scroll ship
that he's on at the end of far from home
is the MC version of the peak
and that now scrolls are working with
him to try to still find their new
homeworld but specifically after all the
events that Thanos he's like okay we
need to keep an eye on the sky that's
supposed to keeping our eye or ear to
the ground
I had the sky and that is now what his
operation is that's his next move what
if that ship is Thanos's to the
sanctuary - Wow and they're like let's
get some Scrolls on this because we
trust them they're our allies we like
them a lot more than we like the Kree
and through the events that we'll see in
the next Captain Marvel film we'll see
the history of the scrolls with
earthlings people like Nick Fury
and they're gonna have a joint strategic
initiative that they work on together
using this ship as their home base which
totally works because if you think of
the way shield approaches things they
have ideas like helicarrier's right yeah
yeah these base these flying base we
want to stay mobile a mobile command but
one that can destroy yeah all right and
then what can they do now that they
couldn't do otherwise they can't clean
up all their enemies I mean I think it's
gonna be useful especially like there
was an other line in far from home where
the scroll versions of Fury and Hill
we're talking about Kree sleeper cells
so maybe there's like there is a war
going on the kree-skrull war is still
going on but now it's a covert cold war
and they're using this ship as a mobile
command center to better defend
themselves against Kree attacks like the
Greece still have an entire army and a
navy and they're gonna need like some
kind of way to fight the Kree whenever
they come there and maybe is just I know
you're not planned for this but I'm
asking anyway maybe is there something
on that ship a star map a star map
that's how they found Luke Skywalker at
the end of course awakens star maps can
be a big deal hey the Spanish Armada
conquered the war the world by having a
great navigation in superior to other
well if they have a map to places that
they'd never even known existed yeah
can we talk about the fact that like
although this is an amazing ship like
it's been around for a while like you
would think just like anything else
the newest version of something is the
best should there be your sanctuary 9
pretty much yeah I think it's more of
the stuff inside the ship that is
probably important so I think I'm not
even sure if this is on the ship or on
the planet where he was a farmer but I
think we saw that 2014 fan OSes double
bladed sword I don't know how you refer
to that weapon fork a fork we saw that
his worst fork is super-strong can cut
into vibranium which is pretty like was
supposed to be the strongest metal on
that we know that we know of yeah
so the idea of like he had this weapon
that eggs is existing somewhere in the
universe either the Avengers who went to
Thanos his home plane we're like oh
that's nifty we should grab that maybe
we'll use if they didn't use it but like
let's take that and we'll do experiments
on it and see what it is or it's on
sanctuary to wherever Thanos parked it
pre farming and I think like that's
something that can potentially be
brought in to does someone experiment
with it and create adamantium I mean
that's a synthetic a synthetic out metal
Alice what adamantium its Wolverines
bones don't say that too fast okay so
you could say our human body flesh bone
yeah I ever think it's weird run
Halloween hell we just have skeletons
everywhere it's like our insides okay so
I mean the main way that most people are
familiar adamantium is that whoever
what's-his-face striker striker
is essentially using Wolverines natural
healing powers to essentially insert
this alloy into his skeleton and make
him an indestructible killing machine
and then other people get parts of it as
it is thrown about the the Marvel
Universe but essentially it become the
next strongest thing you're being
changed if it's literally the worst fork
you can smelt it or whatever and then
use it kind of like once or twice yeah
that's enough to cover like a short
guy's bones yeah and then maybe like one
other characters nails I think it would
also make sense I think I think in most
of the of the comics it's a synthetic
material that sort of made so the idea
that like they took it and sort of
combined it maybe with vibranium maybe
just normal things exists aluminium
don't you can't suddenly have an access
and they yeah they use it for just a
limited amount of things I mean off
screen producer we're also talking about
the fact that potentially maybe they can
make unobtainium from it and then and
then the avatar universe is the Marvel
Universe's and then we just need like a
light saber to fall into one of those
and it's like we can combine them all
and to think that as a kid that
lightsabers should fall through their
own handles and then fall through the
earth and then just like come out the
other side and swing back so when you
say the lab falling lightsaber it brings
me back to that and for that nostalgia
thank you you get one Rogi week it'd be
good to it one a full one yeah his makes
like it's interesting adamantium in the
MCU yeah but I won't give you another I
don't deserve it save us oh ok so mine
is just a pitch for like the plot of the
next guardians of the galaxy movie so
the completely unrelated to my question
question is just like leo
so there's this baseball team right
amazing it's a space ball team well
becomes the GM and he asked you
sabermetrics yep so the spaceship is
where Thanos parked it right and who's
the person who knows where he parked it
where the keys are how to drive it where
her old room is is Gamora so she goes
back home I mean you know right like
she's like this is basically mine I grew
up here I'm all my old posters are in my
bedroom all all my like she like no
sanctuary - is a mobile home like she
knows everything about it she was a
drive issues at work everything she's
risk probably was responsible for
keeping it clean as a kid so she goes
getting great specific to marinas it's
basically like she wants her dad's like
Mustang that she always wanted to have
but he never let her have it
and finally she's like well he's gone
I'm gonna drive this freakin Mustang so
she takes the keys puts the keys in and
she's like you know just pooping around
the galaxy said pooping around the next
guardians of the and fill up any ship
that's traveling in close orbit to just
dump away to drop waves and murder
someone that's what shooting stars are
the guardians of the galaxy are like
yeah let's use this spaceship this is
way better those are this that was the
sound effect but they have to date
amours not on their side yet okay okay
so she's she gets her car back she's
going around
oh yeah cuz they're not together yet
right so she's she disappears she
disappears when she gets her car back
she's like you know eff y'all
and basically the the plot of this movie
is that it it is guardians of the galaxy
they have to get back together but along
the way in space like the whole movie
takes place in space and in space you
can meet all the other characters that
they're trying to involve anyway like a
Silver Surfer right anybody any
basically anybody who occupies phantom
Orlick yeah Adam warlock to be a big one
now yeah yeah you can meet during the
plot of this movie and any way that I
like an airport terminal maybe all these
other like cosmic entities so she does
that I'll also say we could have just
said Peter Quill's looking for her yes
and he just fine because he finds the
ship yeah yeah sort of melding of that
where he's just like people hate there's
so many people that hate Santos she
needs a safe place that she goes
sanctuary to almost instantly put in
peril it's not a sanctuary over teams up
with warlock and something with the MCU
definitely does is the the sins of the
father right they end up we talked about
last we go Iron Man created every yeah
yeah and so it is kind of like yeah
things that they knows did if Gamora is
still technically known as being on his
side maybe people are coming for payback
I like that and Leo would be assist
you're gonna get another rogue II
sniffing distance but real quick I just
some again in a tweet
every time you lose a Rogi for not
knowing yes you okay we broke them too
many things Nick Fury and the scrolls
are squatting and Danis is old ship
hashtag tweet let's say Dennis's sword
used to fill man's bones to coat man's
bones hashtag worse fork that's like the
amount of euphemisms used to coat man's
body worst Bork
I also did a period at Gotham guardians
before that okay Gamora goes home again
it drives new Mustang around a space and
this is this is a threat as well gets
attacked by a bunch of Saveur and then
they'll get back together again hashtag
and then you know Marina you want to
give that to us in the form of a tweet
just just real quick and easy
yeah sanctuary to Gomorrah drives
sanctuary to into the new guardians of
the galaxy movie I'm give Leo another
one on that I'm gonna give you a little
baby one Mirena plug your nose okay
let's do a quick recap before we head
into our final road question which could
decide it and then decide to guys their
wishes come true
alright Eric you have three roadies four
and a half rogue it literally is 1/8 but
you know it's it's a dense alright not
unlike unobtainium right you'll get
something in your hand if you keep doing
that you ready no CEO Bob Iger revealed
in his new memoir that Steve Jobs called
him to tell him how much he hated
Ironman too as did the rest of us
I hope jobs like put me through to Eiger
alright so pitch me on what Steve Jobs
his favorite MCU movie would have been
he liked spider-man what's the most
recent one come coming mmm depart from
afar from I'm sorry sorry far from home
because it's mostly tech based if you
think about it so he's basically all
about the tech he's like yeah finally
it's not about being a superhero it's
about being how smart you are and how
well actually how much you can oppress
other people into making your technology
for you and then charging less yeah I
mean I think that that checks out that I
was gonna say that his favorite is
probably age of Ultron
for a similar reason in that light yeah
he thinks he's yeah he thinks he's the
the smartest person in the world so he's
like I built this AI but I could also
stop the AI in the long run I was able
to said I can make evil and create life
yeah I can do both it's great I think
Steve Jobs favorite MCU film washing
down from heaven was Avengers endgame
because like his products you cannot
experience that one without also
experiencing everything else that was
created by this mega corporation yeah to
have had an iPod to enjoy I don't I mean
like you have to have the entire this
was a weird one so for that I'll assign
everybody gets exactly one they all
break even exactly
so real quick as we wrap up here let's
find out for Leo for Brina five point
eight five point whatever who combined
rogue ease and we form a coalition what
you might be able to let me see what
yours should not determine the rules
yeah right marinas wish that gets to
come true I'll tell you about in one
second but again thanks so much for
watching this episode make sure to get
this as a podcast if you want it first
also thank you so much to our guest Eric
boss Leo Garcia we need to see any we're
following a wire I'm working in D where
now we're doing videos and podcasts
there do that awesome and Marie nobody
up to come in I have no idea I'm gonna
new rocks are sandwich Erickson a brown
people sandwich yay
guys marinas wish as we wrap up I felt
Liliana by the way follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Villa Molina
off-screen producer gets to throw
objects at Eric until he complements
each of us sufficiently I think leo has
a wonderful taste in Jonah Hill films
which is an excellent follow-up
questions of Tycho with teetee yes I
almost made into a video marina brings
so much laughter and joy to every video
she has a wonderfully fair system
distributing Rogge points that as much
as I question it at the end of the day
it makes the most sense for the show
okay we'll keep throwing after the video
thank you guys so much
just just couldn't leave the videos by
faith yeah thank you thank you guys so
much
[Music]